The editor said she broke up with her boyfriend
Oh no, I said it wrong, I said it wrong
It was the editor who said it was her friend.
Breaking up with boyfriend
5 years of relationship
Just like that it's gone
Of course mood hit rock bottom.
How sad is a breakup
You must understand
But sad thing
Not just broken heart
In the hot summer
When you commit two bad habits
Be careful, heart says goodbye to you first, breaking up
The pain is more severethan
the pain of love
Hu Naiwen starts his lecture
I am your old friend, Doctor Hu
I want to share this episode with you
1.Chugging iced water in hot weather harms the heart and may cause a heart attack
2.Sweating nonstop, heart exhaustion, 3 foods to protect your heart
3.Excessive sweating, fatigue, and palpitations? Drink one tea to stay calm
4.Heat stroke, heart discomfort? 1 acupuncture point for self-help
5.Press one spot on the ear to relieve sweating and leg cramps
Chugging iced water in hot weather harms the heart and may cause a heart attack
Hot weather
Are you
Started eating ice cream
Mango Smoothie
Vanilla Ice Cream
Ice Coke
Eat and drink happily
This is called summer
But you know what?
Chug iced water
It could cost lives
Let me give you a real example
A 19-year-old college student
One day he and his friend
After intense exercise and sweating all over on the court.
Gurgle gurgle gurgle
Finished the whole glass of ice drink
My breathing becomes difficult after drinking
He sat down to rest first.
Until the people around him noticed that
his face was pale
Cold sweat all over
Call an ambulance immediately
didn't expect that hadn't been sent to the hospital yet.
heart has stopped beating.
Doctor's judgment
It is an acute myocardial infarction
It's really sad.
He just drank ice water.
How did the heart suddenly have a problem?
Right
People who are used to drinking ice water
Pay attention
The heart is most afraid of alternating hot and cold
Drinking ice water can
cause blood vessels to constrict instantly
Blood pressure spikes
The heart is under great pressure
This may cause
Palpitations
Dizziness
even
Myocardial infarction
In particular
If you have a history of cardiovascular disease
Don't chug iced water.
This is dangerous.
Do Chinese medicine practitioners
tell you to eat less ice?
Tell you three effects
of eating ice on your body
1. Be careful of infertility
From the perspective of traditional Chinese medicine
Hán xié shāng yáng (Transliteration)
don't understand, right?
The body's power
is suppressed.
Poor blood circulation
Drink ice water frequently
It may also cause girls to have
less menstrual blood and menstrual pain
We often hear
Girls, don't eat ice.
Boys don't seem to have this taboo
hey-hey
this is the answer
I'm telling you
Boys eat ice and drink ice water
It will reduce the number of sperm
Young man who wants to be a father
It's difficult
2. Accelerated Aging
Forty looks like sixty
Some studies say
Let the white mice eat ice cream every day
Two and a half months later
They become
Their fur became thinner and sparser.
The action has also slowed down
The same is true for people
Spleen and stomach get cold
Absorption becomes worse
Dull complexion
Loose skin
Feeling of aging
If you want to become more mature
more older
Just eat
It's okay.
3.Injury to the lungs
The Yellow Emperor's Classic of Internal Medicine says
Xíng hán yǐn lěng zé shāng fèi (Transliteration)
The wind blows outside
You feel cold
Drink ice water again
It will hurt your lungs
When you are lack of yáng qì (Transliteration)
The whole person seems to be wearing too little
caught a cold when the wind blew
If severe
The lungs become wet and cold
beginning
cough
Runny nose
Too out of breath to lie down
It's really miserable.
But from July to September
The temperature soared to 38°C 39°C
It's almost 40°C
Of course you have to drink ice to cool down.
Ice is not untouchable
The key is not to overdo it.
really want an ice drink.
Keep the drink in your mouth first
A little warmer.
Wait until it is close to body temperature
Then swallow it slowly
Give your lungs a little tenderness
Such stimulation
It won't be that big
Habit 2: Sweating and almost fainting, eat two foods to supplement potassium
Sweating is the right thing to do.
It is a dehumidification health
If you do it wrong
But it causes heart exhaustion
Why
because
Potassium is important for the heart
In fact, potassium, calcium, etc.
All ions are important
Helps maintain a normal heartbeat
and neurological function
Once too much is lost
The heart will protest.
When you exercise or jog
Sweating not only takes away water
It also contains electrolytes such as sodium and potassium.
Brought it back together
What to supplement if you sweat too much
Drink some after exercise
Drinks containing electrolytes
Like sports drinks
To replenish water and electrolytes
Helps relieve fatigue
In addition to drinking sports drinks
What can I eat if I sweat a lot?
banana
kiwi
Eat
Supplement potassium and energy
Not only that
The mung bean soup sold at the corner of your alley
It is also rich in potassium
Drink it to help your body
flush out water
Reduce cardiovascular burden
You can also eat bitter melon
Very good
You all remember what I said
bitter melon to relieve heat
Protect cardiovascular system
It can also stabilize blood sugar
Traditional Chinese medicine says xīn shǔ huǒ kǔ wèi rù xīn (Transliteration)
Eat a little bitter in summer
Make your heart stronger
Excessive sweating, fatigue, and palpitations? Drink one tea to stay calm
Are you someone who has a palpitating heart
or gets tired easily?
There is a kind of tea
It can replenish heart blood
improve
Improve dry mouth and palpitations
It is
Ophiopogonis Radix and Schisandra chinensis Tea
Wow, such good tea
How to soak?
You prepare 5 grams of Ophiopogon Radix
Schisandra chinensis3 grams
5 grams of ginseng
Or ginseng root is also OK
Put them in the thermos
Pour 600cc of hot water
Simmer it for 10 minutes
can drink it now
This tea has Ophiopogonis Radixand Schisandra chinensis
Nourishes the Heartyīn (Transliteration)
Improve heart function
Increase body fluids
You often have dry mouth
Truly an essential good formula
Doctor, the weather is hot.
I sweat easily.
The whole body is sticky
Thirst and general weakness
Feeling exhausted
Can I drink, please?
Ophiopogonis Radix and Schisandra chinensis Tea
You have this symptom
Come
Ophiopogonis Radix and Schisandra chinensis Tea
In fact, it isshēng mài yǐn (Transliteration)
Just drink it.
With it
won’t have to worry about sweating
in the summer.
Heat stroke, heart discomfort? 1 acupuncture point for self-help
Doctor Hu
A few days ago, my friend rode a motorcycle
Running business outside
He returns to the company before leaving get off work
just parked the motorcycle.
Suddenly turned pale
Sweating
Chest tightness
fainted soon after.
Fortunately, a doctor came by
Rescue him.
What a blessing!
yes
This sounds like
Typical heat stroke and insufficient xīn qì (Transliteration)
In severe cases
Did you know
It may cause shock
What if this happens
to you or someone around you
in the future?
How do we provide first aid?
There is an acupuncture point
can get first aid immediately
That is theRén zhōng xué (Transliteration)
What about thisRén zhōng xué (Transliteration)?
It is an acupuncture point belonging to thedū mài(Transliteration)?
The dū mài (Transliteration) is the main vessel of yáng qì (Transliteration) in the human body.
It is responsible for monitoring the yáng qì (Transliteration) of the entire body.
Affects the circulation of qi and blood throughout the body
When a person has heat stroke, faints, or goes into shock
even
Even heart discomfort
When
about to faint
Immediately use the tip of your nail
Press theRén zhōng xué (Transliteration)vigorously
Make him feel pain
This stimulates the brain
It makes people regain consciousness quickly
Wow, thatRén zhōng xué (Transliteration)
It's really important.
Yes, if you press theRén zhōng xué (Transliteration)and there is no response
You must call an ambulance immediately
Of course, if have a reaction, call an ambulance.
Because it's a matter of life and death
So as not to miss the golden rescue time
Nighttime sweating and leg cramps — press one spot on the ear for relief.
I sweated a lot last night
have a calf cramp.
Are cramps
caused by sweating?
You asked a very good question.
In fact, Chinese medicine and Western medicine
Views on cramps
Not exactly the same
Right?
Western medicine's view on muscle cramps
A common cause is
electrolyte imbalance.
Minerals like calcium and magnesium
Or it's too little.
Or maybe it's just too much.
It may lead to
Abnormal muscle contraction
Causes cramps
So how to deal with it?
Western medicine believes there is a gland
called the parathyroid gland.
It's behind the thyroid gland.
There are four parathyroid glands
This parathyroid gland
On the ear
There is actually an acupuncture point
called Parathyroid gland acupoint
Where is it?
Between the earlobe and the tragus
We call this the earlobe.
This place is called the tragus.
This one in front is called the tragus.
The one opposite is called the antitragus.
At the position of the antitragus
A little bit above the earlobe
called Parathyroid gland
It is related to calcium metabolism
You can adjust calcium metabolism
with just press
Redistribute calcium ions
Then the cramps were relieved immediately.
Wow, didn't expect to press my ears
It can also cure cramps.
How does traditional Chinese medicine view
muscle cramps?
Traditional Chinese medicine believes that muscle cramps
Because
It is because of the qì xuè xū ér jīn mài shī yǎng (Transliteration)
Especially like you sweated a lot
yesterday
Because Chinese medicine believes hàn wéi xīn zhī yè (Transliteration)
Sweat is the liquid that comes out of the heart.
What is the fluid that comes out of the heart?
Is it blood?
That's it
Meaning
Sweat is the body fluid produced by the heart
You sweat too much.
It may cause
Qi and blood flowed away together
TheJīn mài (Transliteration)are not nourished
There will be spasms
muscle cramps, etc.
It turns out that sweat too much
It will also harm the heart and QI blood.
Right
In addition to sweating
And what else
Too much stool
Urinating too much
It is equivalent to saying
Too many things have been excluded.
It will also make
Body water and electrolytes
Massive loss
May cause muscle cramps
Friends who like this video
Please click the super thank you button below the video
Give us support